hurry is with us mike mantua what mike
he's probably like why do i want you to
coach me in anything you're what the
hell are you gonna coach me with
uh two how are you buddy
i'm doing well guys thank you guys for
having me
you know when we think back to last week
week of the super bowl we had you we got
to see some of your family members down
there when you reflect back on the past
year
how do you think you've personally
changed the most
well i i'd say from a football
standpoint i've i've changed a lot as a
player
you know because a lot more
is expected and
you you got to do a lot more on your own
uh whereas in college
that that wasn't the case you know you
had your coaches
kind of guiding the way for you and
you also had school work to deal with in
the nfl
you don't necessarily have schoolwork
you know and i hear that from time to
time and it makes a ton of sense like
you've got actually a lot more free time
at the nfl level
because when you're done you're done
you're left your own devices you have to
decide how you're going to budget the
rest of your day when are you going to
spend time studying your playbook when
are you going to spend time studying
film are you going to get an extra
workout in are you going to maybe do
things that are gonna distract from your
ability to be ready for work the next
day it takes a lot more discipline than
it does when you're in college
i agree uh i would i would say yes to
that point um because you definitely
have a lot of down time in the offseason
um
you know and you just got to find ways
to keep yourself busy whether that's
you know
spending more time with your family
during the off off-season
um
you know
doing things to help get your body right
for this upcoming season so
um you know for me this is my first true
off-season
and
uh
i'd say at this point i'm i'm i'm
enjoying it right now but starting next
week we get right back into things yeah
yeah i mean two of that i'm interested i
was in your shoes once at rookie where
i'm going wait practice is over we had
our last meeting it's time to go home
right and then i look at like brad
johnson who's the starting quarterback
and he's going into the meeting room and
doing those things and like in a watch
more film who
what was that moment to you where you
were like oh wait you know was it ryan
fitzpatrick
did he teach you the way or did you just
see him hanging out in the facility and
said wait i better hang around too how
did that all shake out
yeah i
i actually seen um ryan a good amount of
times after meetings were done he'd go
into another meeting room you know by
himself
and you know i'd pop in and ask him what
he'd be doing and he'd tell me pull up a
seat and
really he just talked me through his
thoughts on you know how he tries to
break down the film in practice and how
he tries to break down defenses
so to that point ryan ryan has helped me
tremendously
you know with
doing things on my own and
also
you know knowing how to study the film
you know two i remember talking to you
after one of your first few starts it
was one of the victories and
and you you said to me that you were
surprised that it wasn't as difficult as
you thought it was going to be there
weren't as many different looks as you
thought you would see did that change
once you created more film and defenses
could get a better feel for what you
were doing did it get more complicated
did you see more looks
well i guess
that that was kind of taken out of
context
and i think
what i
kind of meant to say was
you know our coaches made it easier for
me
like going out there because of the
preparation they had with the scout
defense you know i think the scout
defense did a great job
and helped prepping me you know our
coaches did a great job as well
um i didn't necessarily mean
that the nfl was was easy and that it'd
be a breeze um you know it's going
against all these defenses
um i mean all these guys are really good
um so
you know every time you got to bring
your a game
you just got to expect the unexpected
yeah no there's no doubt that's part of
playing quarterback um
you know we're fellow lefties we know
that i want to know some of the stories
because i'm sure this happened it
happened with me you start to throw
balls on the first day of training camp
and everyone going whoa whoa wait that
ball's different let me catch a few like
was it a huge adjustment for the
receivers getting used to the lefty on
the roster
i'd say the receivers did a great job
they
they
they weren't complaining about anything
as far as the rotation of the ball
um
you know maybe the center maybe in the
wind maybe in the wind the ball can
can get picked up a little bit and
you know shift uh one way
uh than the other but
other than that i i heard nothing from
the receivers um you know they they'll
even tell you that
you know
you got to catch the ball regardless if
it spins right or if it spins left
with ryan fitzpatrick you seem to handle
very well the reality that your head
coach brian flores would whenever he
felt like it was the right thing to do
put him into the game i mean you've got
a teammate but there's inherent
competition how did you manage that
because you seem to handle that like i
said extremely well
when when it would happen that the coach
would decide to make a change during a
game
yeah well
you know i i think as a quarterback and
as leader of you know the team
you know the
you you have the best interest for the
team and you know i i would say the same
thing with our coaching staff especially
with flow he has you know the best
interest for the team and
you know if
i can't get the job done someone else
can
you know
that's that's just the way it's gonna
that's just the way the cookie's gonna
crumble and you know flo
thought that uh fitz would give us a
better opportunity in those moments
which fitz did um in the las vegas game
you know and it was also good learning
moments for me too
um to be able to watch you know instead
of always hearing what fitz has to say
being able to actually
see him go out and do it so that was
pretty cool i'm amazed with how you
handle adversity i really am just like
with that question right there with mike
aston about the fitzpatrick you know you
always seem to keep a smile on your face
and everything and now you gotta hear
like oh desean watson to the dolphins
and all that how do you compartmentalize
all that and always stay so positive to
her
well i think a lot has to do with
um you know my faith like i i talk about
my faith a lot
um
you know but anything that that goes
goes around
you know that
i mean i i can control what i can
control and you know my focus is just
trying to get better um with this year
one to year two jump and trying to be
you know the best version of me that i
can be for the miami dolphins
what's your specific focus to uh going
into year two what give me something
tangible that you're working on to try
to take your game to the next level
going into your second season
i'm sorry could you repeat that again
sure give me something tangible you're
working on as you try to take your game
to the next level going into your second
season
yeah i i would say that you know more so
pre-snap versus post snap um you know
reads with the defenses and then also
getting better with
my pre-snap operations as far as uh
communication up front with the guys
with the line
um
you know redirecting protection
you know and just seeing the field a lot
better and being more comfortable in the
back there
yeah is that like what was the biggest
hurdle for you was it the
physical adjustment to the nfl as far as
like ooh the windows are smaller and i
still got to throw this this is open or
was it more of the mental gymnastics of
man learning the the playbook and
getting in and out of the huddle and all
the checks what what did you find more
difficult
i'd i definitely say the mental
gymnastics of of the game um
you know just
trying to compartmentalize everything
with the playbook
and then understanding where everyone
goes
the snap count the play clock
just everything going through your mind
and
uh just
you know trying to work as
uh you know hard and as efficient as
possible
uh to make this year once year two jump
you know two yacht you talked earlier
about how much more time
of your time was consumed when you were
in college and i think what made your
first year in the nfl even more glaring
the pandemic no off season program
do you ever wonder how much different
your rookie season would have been if
you'd have had that on field prep that
you just didn't get going into your
first season in the nfl
well sometimes things don't always work
out the way they're supposed to um
you know and
i i wasn't the only uh rookie you know
playing without
uh you know a normal
what a normal nfl year would look like
so
you know we we all of us rookies this
past year have been given the same
really slate you know we all been given
a clean slate and
some of us made the best of our
opportunities and some of us didn't and
you know i'd say i need to do a better
job
making uh good use of my opportunity
you know one thing we haven't talked
about and i didn't really hear you talk
about it much during the year you know
you got drafted
we knew your health wasn't at a hundred
percent i doubt you were at 100 feeling
normal at the start of training camp
like where are you
right now in that you know area as far
as before the injury do you feel like
man i'm totally back totally normal
hitting on all cylinders
i'd say physically and mentally i i'm
i'm back um
you know i i think it's it's a
continuing process of you know
stretching
[Music]
you know just strengthening you know the
parts around the hip and you know just
continuing to get better stronger faster
you know and and hoping to be
a lot better this upcoming season
hey tell us what you have going on with
truest bank
yeah so um you know i'm really excited
to be working with truiss
who recently announced that they're an
official retail bank
of the nfl
which is cool because
um
the reason i'm working with them is
we have a shared passion and
like our shared passion is inspiring and
building better lives and better
communities and so today i'll be
launching my tour foundation
awesome which is focused on youth
initiatives uh health and wellness and
other charitable causes and uh
jewish's truest is one of the partners
who is helping
to make a meaningful difference with
that so
thank you
well that's great great stuff too hey
one more before we go i saw ryan
fitzpatrick talking this week about
wanting to play next year do you want
him to come back or are you kind of
ready to say i've got this i don't need
to have a relief pitcher
yeah well i think i you know i i've
learned a tremendous amount from ryan um
you know he's he's a great person and
i think we'll continue to have this
strong relationship uh whether he comes
back to miami or whether he he doesn't
um you know but i've learned a
tremendous amount and i know that he's
someone that i can always call
throughout the season or throughout the
year
all right hey tua great seeing you as
always all the best to your family and
all the best as you get ready for year
two in the nfl thanks for some of your
time thank you guys very much
good luck there he is
yeah
well that's a good question that last
one
yeah that was a good question though
because i mean
no he doesn't i know how i would he
doesn't want i know how it's patrick but
right he wants ryan ryan i love you but
you got to go right he wants what most
hell out of a rookie top 10 quarterbacks
he doesn't want a guy breathing down his
neck and doing that you know there is
something to that so that'll uh that
would be interesting to watch and what
miami does do in that whole situation
and i respect him so much for handling
that aspect of it the way that he did
could you imagine some of the other guys
we've seen over the years some of the
guys who come in with that mentality
that they're entitled that this is my
job i think of a ryan leave how would
ryan leaf have handled having a veteran
quarterback who's been around forever
right tapping him on the shoulder saying
i've got it from here um so
he he really did handle himself well and
i think
going through that adversity and that
kind of maturity and that attitude it's
going to serve him well down the road
yeah i agreed i mean it's battle tested
it's hardened you know certainly and
that will help them you know having to
deal with this adversity everything
about that and you know i do think
that's a real aspect too that we we we
hit on a little bit and i wish i wanted
to follow up a little bit and just go
like where were you exactly this year
because it sounds like he was still
involved in some of the maintenance of
his hip and dealing with those issues i
doubt he was totally a hundred percent
the tool before the injury this season
so be interesting to see what strides he
makes physically and if he looks a
little different that way next year too
hey they've got a great team and he does
have to deal with all this whole desean
watson i mean you know it's hey if look
this this was the this was the the
weirdest one for us because we both
really like the kid
he's in a tough spot he can't ignore the
elephant in the room right and and i
remember when i saw the list of of all
of the people who were going to have
this week's like man i
i admire him for stepping into the fray
because he did a bunch of different
shows he was on with dan patrick i mean
when you do this you are in the meat
grinder and when your name's in the news
not for reasons that are ideal not
because you were the offensive rookie of
the year you had a great season no you
got you got benched a couple of times
yeah now you have deshawn watson hanging
over your head i'll tell you what just
just this experience is gonna be a
character builder for him yeah you're
right it is it's you know it's part of
the nfl and i know we look at the
superstars and you know how awesome it
is to be a starting quarterback
superstar in the nfl but man the rest of
these quarterbacks are are fighting for
their lives for them for the most part
um but it is gonna be you're right it's
it's a it's he's gonna have to answer
some tough questions it's gonna be tough
questions because of what we talked
about all year right mike i mean hey
there was three quarterbacks taken in
the top ten he was the second of three
i think and we're again i'm i want to
clarify this we're rooting for tua i
like the guy
but he was clearly third
he was clearly third out of the three
quarterbacks that were taken in the top
ten and when that happens
you know yes the microscope goes on and
people focus it even more to go wait
what the hell went on here why is he not
as good as we thought and he's got to
deal with that right now yeah and look
it did not help him at all that justin
herbert was taken immediately after him
right one spot later and
became an instant superstar high level
you already got him in your top ten
right right yeah i mean justin herbert
is already you know he's in the
conversation one of the five best pure
passers in football already for my money
for some of the things he did there you
know he is extremely talented superstar
level type talent he really does and uh
yeah good for justin herbert but yes
that puts more pressure on tua and his
situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports